[Music]
the royal family breathing a sigh of
relief today the Islamic extremists who
called for attacks on Prince George and
encouraged acts of terrorism in the UK
has been convicted 32 year old who's
nein Rashid posted photos of the four
year old heir to the throne last October
including the address of his preschool
along with the message even the royal
family will not be left alone school
starts early he was arrested in November
convicted yesterday and could face life
in prison
despite the scary threat the Royals kept
things business as usual that's George's
dad Prince William attending a garden
party yesterday
dressed in top hat and tails the future
king accompanied his grandmother and
cousin Eugenie on the grounds of
Buckingham Palace completing his outfit
gray pants lavender tie and a solitaire
matching blossom on his lapel his other
half Kate Middleton skipped the event
she isn't back to making public
appearances yet after the birth of son
Louie in April it's the second of three
garden parties the Queen is hosting
Harry and Megan attended the last one
but not this one so what exactly is a
garden party it's a way for the Queen to
recognize and reward public service
guests have a chance to chat with the
Queen and partake in the 27,000 cups of
tea 20,000 sandwiches and 20,000 slices
of cake that are served
[Music]
[Applause]